one of the things I was gonna do in
Germany was go to Landstuhl Medical
Center which is the main hospital in
Germany where people come right off the
battlefield and they go to the hospital
I walked in and I had a USO hat on and I
didn't know what to say or how to start
it and somebody looked at me and he said
Lieutenant Dan
[Music]
hello and welcome to the sunday special
our special guest today is Gary Sinise
he has a brand new book out we're going
to be talking with him about his journey
and acting his journey in service his
work with the military we'll get to all
of that but first with only days left
until Valentine's it seems like
everybody is selling bouquets drug
stores supermarkets gas stations you
name it your special someone deserves
better than that and that's why every
Valentine's I order from my Rose
authority 1-800 flowers calm right now
you can get 18 red roses for $29.99 or
upgrade it to 24 assorted roses plus a
vase for 10 bucks more that's an amazing
offer from 1-800 flowers 18 red roses
for $29.99 or upgraded to 24 assorted
roses plus a vase for 10 bucks more
roses from 1-800 flowers are picked at
their peak they're shipped overnight to
ensure freshness and her amazement every
time I go out of town I send my wife
1-800 flowers because that's the kind of
husband I am you should be great also 18
red roses for $29.99 or upgrade so 24
assorted roses plus a vase for $10 more
it's an amazing last-minute offer pick
your delivery date let 1-800 flowers
handle the rest when it comes to
Valentine's I don't settle for anything
less than my rose Authority 1-800
flowers come again to order 18 red roses
for $29.99 or upgrade it to 24 assorted
roses Plus that vase for 10 bucks more
go to 1-800 flowers calm / Shapiro's
thats 1-800 flowers calm / apparel hurry
the offer expires Monday now I'll also
remind you you need to subscribe over at
daily wire com2 here the final question
will be asking Gary today because that
question is going to be so monumentally
interesting that you're going to want to
get behind that pay wall so go check us
out go subscribe over at daily wire.com
Gary thanks so much for stopping by I
really appreciate it good to see you
so his brand-new book the book is
grateful American a journey from self to
service and it really is an inspiring
book we're living a really divided time
obviously Gary and it's it's really I
think a difficult time for most
Americans but it's a really uniting
story so let's start from the beginning
how did you get into acting when you
grow up you're telling you earlier they
grew up on the south side of Chicago how
do you go from there to world-famous
movie star well it's a bit of a long
journey but I was there's a story in the
book where I where I talk about that
just a circumstance and I stumbled into
it really or somebody stumbled into me
when I was in high school I was kind of
a
rock-and-roller I had blatant bans I
said I played in bands from the time I
was like 5th to 6th grade or something
like that I had guitars and played in
rock bands then I I did that in junior
high school then I got into high school
and I had a lot of trouble in high
school I was I was academically I was
really struggling this was in this late
60s and early 70s it was a time that the
crazy things were going on Vietnam War
was happening during this time I got
that caught up in some it's a mischief
there during during my high school years
and I was I was struggling I was having
a lot of trouble and you know one of the
things I did to escape was was play
music and play and play in bands and I
was standing in this hallway one one
time when I was a sophomore in high
school
this is Highland Park High School in
Illinois on the north side of Chicago
North suburbs I'm standing in a hallway
and this little lady this little blonde
lady comes blowing down I mean she was
like a hurricane or typhoon or something
just whipping by and I'm standing here
with my rock-and-roll pals you know
looking pretty scrubby and you know
grungy and everything she turns around
she goes she goes up have you ever been
in a play I said no no we're rockers you
know and she said well I'm directing
West Side Story and you look perfect for
one of the gang members so come an
audition for the play and she blew off
down that wall and we kind of looked at
each other and laughed and everything
like that but the year before when I was
a freshman I went to another high school
in Glen Ellyn Illinois and it was at
Glenbard West and they had done West
Side Story at this school when I was a
freshman and I went to see it and I
thought it was you know be fun to get on
stage and play gang member and you know
you dance and Rumble and all this stuff
so you know I thought about it a little
bit and after school there was the
audition and then I decided well let me
just go down there and just see what's
going on so I was standing outside the
audition all the pretty girls are going
in didn't to audition I'm surfing so I
turn to my bass player who was in my
back
I said let's go in and we went in and
they handed me a script I didn't know
what I was doing or anything like that
and I got up there I started stumbling
around making jokes people were laughing
and she put me in the play and that was
the beginning of my acting after that it
changed my whole life I mean I would I
was really a struggling kid I was having
a lot of trouble and and I write about
that in the book you know and I think I
think young people can might be able to
to connect to that you know I was just
not academic academically I had a lot of
trouble I never learned how to read and
write properly I don't think when I was
in you know those fundamentals you learn
in first second third grade I just
wasn't paying attention at all I could
barely read so when I got up there and
audition for the play and then I got
into play and then I found this
community of people that kind of really
I've just felt comfortable in it and
then I just wanted to do it over and
over and over and all through high
school I kept acting in plays and I
ended up being one of them you know one
of the top guys in the theatre
department and because I was such a
screw-up you know early in high school I
didn't have enough credits to graduate
on time with my class so I had to go
back to high school for a final semester
so I was supposed to graduate in 1973
and we we say in the book that I
graduated in 1973 and a half that's when
I graduate I kept doing it and I met one
of my best friends in high school who's
remained one of my best friends for
years Jeff Perry who was a well-known
actor here in town and then he was he
was in the play West Side Story and Jeff
and I became fast friends best friends
did a lot of work together in high
school he went off to college and then I
started Steppenwolf theater and he came
and worked with us in one play and then
we founded what has become a theatre
that's lasted for 45 years now he talked
a little bit about Steppenwolf theater
so for folks who don't know step-over
theaters now one the most storied
theaters in the country and you were
obviously a founder of it what was the
original idea of it and
what do you think the legacy of it has
been well the original idea was just
kids wanting to do plays that was it we
just wanted a you know kind of in that
Mickey Rooney Judy Garland let's put on
a play kind of thing and we did that and
we found a church kind of that would let
us use the church during the week and we
would rehearse our play isn't perform on
the you know on on Friday and the
Thursday Friday Saturday nights and and
that became the foundation of
Steppenwolf theatre you know was really
started by eighteen year old kids
seventeen eighteen year old kids and now
this theater as I said it's I mean this
was 1974 we got this going so it's 45
years old now now we own four buildings
were building another one I mean it's
it's it's kind of crazy when you look
back at it and you see what teenagers
with a passion and a dream and a desire
and enough energy and and kind of this
you don't know what you don't know kind
of attitude gets you and it it laid the
groundwork for something that we built
as we moved from Highland Park Illinois
into the city of Chicago
renovated another space that David Mamet
had originally started we took that over
we were in there for eight years and
then we built a building from the ground
up and now we own three or four
buildings in the same area I mean it is
a pretty amazing American story and
something that probably could only
happen in America
that a high school screw-up could be
doing this sort of stuff just you know
through sheer willpower and creativity
because we now live in a time when
people tend to spend a lot of time
thinking about how victimized they are
how difficult they've had it you did
sound like you didn't come from a
background where you were significantly
privileged beyond sort of the normal
privilege of living in the United
and I write about the family in the book
my dad was a film editor in Chicago he
started he started learning in the film
business when he was in the Navy he
processed film that was being he was in
the Navy during the Korean War at one
point they said you want to go on a ship
or you want a camera and he took the
camera he started taking pictures then
they put him in the lab at the Pentagon
you know at the inn and know it Anna
kostya it's a it's a naval base right
there
in DC and they put him in there and he
was receiving the top-secret film that
was coming back from the front in Korea
and he had top-secret clearance and he
would process this film and take a
little over the Pentagon and they would
analyze the the war footage to help them
with their battle plans and things like
that
so he learned the film business he was
editing things and they all that and
then when he got out of the Navy he went
back to Chicago and started his own film
film company it was he made a modest
living it wasn't the you know the
tremendous living but he moved he moved
us from the south side where I grew up
in I was born in Blue Island Illinois
and lived in Harvey Illinois and then we
moved up to the northern suburbs of
Highland Park and that's where I went to
school that's where I live got into
acting that's where I met Jeff Perry
that's where Steppenwolf started and it
was really it was just I was kind of a
kid who was always kind of aimless my
dad was working all the time I described
it in the book and I was sort of on my
own my mom had her hands full dealing
with my my sister and my brother and her
mother and her sister and I was just
kind of crazy out there learning things
on my own
trying to figure it all out so I at an
early age I think I learned this sort of
do-it-yourself go at it if you can think
it you can do it sort of attitude you
know don't wait around for somebody hand
you something and so that's that's
that's where all that came from and and
you know I continued to do that as time
went on so how did you get from Chicago
out to Hollywood so I did my own parents
my dad and mom are both from Chicago
they ended up in Hollywood because my
dad wanted to do scouring for films that
was the dream that never worked out for
him how did you end up out here well
it's a combination thing you know I
started Steppenwolf with my buddies Jeff
Perry and Terry Kinney and then my
parents in 1977 they moved to LA from
Chicago because my dad was a film editor
he had a business in Chicago they wanted
to open a West Coast office so he opened
that our office out here in 1977 and 19
seventy-nine I took a little break and
came out here took a little break from
Steppenwolf came out here live with my
parents to try to get in the movie
business I there's some funny stories
about some of the things I did back then
but it didn't work out
I just really struggled I couldn't get
in the door I was trying to sneak on to
Lots I was trying to audition for things
I couldn't get a job I couldn't get an
agent you know it was just it was just a
terrible time they kept telling me to go
to get acting lessons and I had this
theater company in Chicago that I worked
with and they said and I would tell them
about that and they said well I never
heard of it go get some lessons and so
it was really frustrating frustrating
frustrating time so I went back to
Chicago I went back to my theatre
company ended up being the artistic
director started directing a lot and
directing plays and some of the plays
that I was doing just hit one of them
was one of them is called true West by
Sam Shepard John Malkovich and I were in
that together yeah and we moved it to
New York it was the first play that we
moved into New York from Steppenwolf
Malkovich was an early member of the
company we worked together a lot and did
that play and it was it was just a big
hit it was huge it was a big hit for us
we moved it to New York first thing
there Malkovich became a movie star
after doing that play and I kept
directing went back to Chicago kept
directing ended up doing some some plays
that were really in doing well one of
those plays was called orphans that John
Mahoney rest his soul was in along with
Kevin Anderson and Terry Kinney we did
it off-broadway it was a big hit and I
was offered a movie deal by David Putnam
who he produced Chariots of Fire he
produced a mission he produced killing
The Killing Fields he was a big producer
and they gave him a job running Columbia
Pictures and he came to see that play
and eventually they offered me a
directing deal at Columbia Pictures and
I was running Steppenwolf and doing
things at Steppenwolf and I felt well it
was time to to kind of break away do
some other things so I came out here and
took that deal and was with Columbia
Pictures for a couple years trying to
find something to direct for them that
was our deal they it was a first-look
deal so they got the first look at
anything that I wanted to do I never
found anything that that they wanted to
do but I found another project that I
ended up doing for another studio and
that was the first movie I directed I
called miles from home with Richard Gere
and Kevin Anderson but Brian Dennehy
Helen Hunt banana bunnelby Ann Miller a
bunch of people are in that and you know
it was a good first try that eventually
I think my second movie was much better
it was of mice and men I knew that story
very very well Malkovich and I had done
it on stage you know like 10 or 12 years
before I directed the movies so I was
able to get the rights for from Alain
Steinbach to make that into a movie and
I was a little more sure handed I think
at that one but that it was 87 1987 when
I moved to Hollywood and and then after
of mice and men Forrest Gump came along
and you know there are you going well in
a second I'm gonna ask you about the
differences between directing and acting
and how it is to to be behind the camera
as opposed to in front of the camera but
first let's talk about making your
business more efficient hye-rin can be
pretty time-consuming you post a job as
several online job boards only to get
tons of the wrong resumes then you have
to sort through all those resumes just
to find a few people with the right
skills and experience those job sites
that overwhelm you with the wrong
resumes they're not smart that's why you
should do the smart thing and go to zip
recruiters comm slash been guest
unlike other job sites zip recruiter
finds qualified candidates for you it's
powerful matching technology scans
thousands of resumes to identify people
with the right skills education and
experience and then actively invites
them to apply for your job so you get
qualified candidates fast it's no wonder
that zip recruiter is rated number one
by employers in the u.s. that rating
comes from hiring sites on trust pilot
with over a thousand reviews right now
my listeners can try zip recruiter for
free at this exclusive web addresses zip
recruiters
/ been guests if you love this show show
your support for it and zip recruiter by
going to zip recruiter comm / been guest
be en GU est that zip recruiter comm /a
been gasps zip recruiter is indeed the
smartest way to hire again check us out
at zip recruiter comm / up been guest
alright so back to your directing career
so you came out here as a director and
yet I think most people know you more as
an actor than they do as a director
what is the difference for you between
being behind the camera in front of the
camera which do you prefer and and did
it help you as an actor to be a director
in in theatre it helped me as a director
to be an actor I would say because most
of what I know as a director is from
working with other actors and being an
actor myself so I I always when I would
direct I would you know I would direct
from an actor's point of view how can we
make this you know dramatically viable
in the in the story how can we punch up
this energy here how could we do that
you know how would I play it you know I
think you know maybe I can have some
ideas about that and impart those to to
other people but and how do you shape
the story you know to have it be
compelling so I'm always looking at that
and what I know about directing movies
or you know which I've only done a
couple of is is what I know about acting
and directing plays ya know so I just
kind of you know I didn't study all that
I went to high school I didn't go to
college I I just went right into
founding Steppenwolf theater and working
in this basement of a Catholic school
actually is where the the original
Steppenwolf was in Highland Park and
this this you know I went then there was
this big empty basement at this closed
down Catholic school and we asked the
priest if if he'd let us use it and he
did and we paint him like one one dollar
a year for a tax write-off and so in
there we developed our skills you know
we were isolated we weren't in the city
of Chicago where there you know there's
a lot of other theatres there we
in Highland Park Illinois there's only
one Little Theatre there and it was us
so we weren't distracted by a lot of
other things and we stayed in the
basement and just worked on our skills
worked on our work that kind of tuned up
the way we we approach things
our whole ensemble approach was
developed in those early days when we
were kids and I've carried that through
through all these years of directing and
acting carried it all those fundamentals
that we learned as kids you know stay
there and we learned it together
really so you've done theater and he was
out in film and you've also done a lot
of TV I mean I want to ask you about the
transition from film to TV so now TV is
not considered a step down for a long
time there it was like if you're in the
films and then he went to TV that was
considered a step down now you're seeing
all sorts of mainstream actors big
actors and Furman's to step up to move
to TV you were really one of the
pioneers in that actually what was it
like to move from the big screen to the
small screen what was that a bit of a
culture shock how did that work it was a
little bit I remember being a little
hesitant about it I mean I was offered a
television series in 19 2004 and I had
done a few little television things
prior to that I did a television movie
with James Woods in 1989 called my my
name is Bill W played a good supporting
role in that had had a couple episodic
roles but nothing I was always looking
for the big movie part and or the big
part on stage or something like that
never considered settling down into a
television series until it was
presenting itself to me and then you
know was it was CSI New York and it was
already a successful franchise they had
done CSI Vegas and then there was CSI
Miami and now they were gonna spin off
the third show with him within four
years or something like that I mean CSI
Vegas came out two years later they had
a another show in Miami and two years
after that they had another show they
were putting up in in in New York CSI
New York so I mean they spun this
franchise off very quickly and I knew
they had a lot of
vested in this franchise CBS was going
to put a lot into it
I met with Anthony xikar who created the
CSI franchise had a good meeting with
him and we had a good talk and I was you
know at that time I was very focused on
supporting our military it was post
September 11th I was working with
veterans I was supporting FDNY in New
York and fire family transport
Foundation and 9/11 family members who
had been affected by that terrible
tragedy Anthony wanted my character to
to be somebody who was affected
personally by September 11th lost his
wife on September 11th he's also police
officer I knew a lot of veterans and
police officers and they who were
personally affected by that so I
connected to the idea of playing a 9/11
family member and they first responder
pretty quickly because I had been
supporting them and once I got through
the idea the the question of what will
it be like to play the same guy week
after week after week after week once I
got through that you know all the other
things were staring me at the face in
the face steady work staying home a good
franchise paycheck all the all these
things and if it's successful there it
would be you know a very rewarding
personally and financially sad which it
was so it was the right thing at the
right time to go from you know what I
was doing to television and after the
first year of struggling through
figuring out what the show was and
everything like that I really embrace
the idea that I was playing the same guy
every week and had this steady job and
during that period and I write about in
the book all the things I was doing to
help the military and to put support
various military charities and all this
stuff the fact that I had that steady
work and had that that job gave me a
means
to support many things that I believed
in that I never dreamed about and it
really was the the chapter in the book
where I talk about this it's called
perfect timing and the timing could not
have been better at a you know with what
I was doing on my charitable side and
the service work and getting getting
handed this television series so you've
worked on the stage you've worked on the
big screen you've worked on the small
screen which did you prefer and and why
because you see people who are sometimes
successful on stage who can't make the
transition to film people who are
successful on film who can make the
transition to stage you've done all
three which did you prefer what we're
sort of the upsides and downsides you
know I prefer employment that's that's
what I would say there and I like being
involved in things that kind of makes
sense to me that that's it you know I've
directed I've acted in all the mediums
and you know the parts that I've done on
stage have been very rewarding generally
you know the what I've done in film and
television has generally been rewarding
and valuable and I don't feel like it's
been time unwell spent so it's hard to
say Ben um you know that I prefer one
over the other
each one has given me something special
and you know I've done what I think is
good work in all those mediums well the
book also obviously goes into deep
detail and I think necessary detail
about your relationship with the US
military so when did you first start
getting involved with all of your
outreach efforts on behalf of the
military with first responders with with
police across the country well did it
start with Lieutenant Dan and Forrest
Gump or were you doing work with the
military before that well that was that
was certainly part of it you know the
the the Forrest Gump character was a
wounded veteran lost both his legs and
suffering terribly from post-traumatic
stress and and playing that part led me
to start working with our wounded 25
years ago I mean Forrest Gump came out
years ago this year so June 6th this
summer it'll be 25 years
that was certainly a part of getting
involved with with our wounded but prior
to that actually I I began supporting
Vietnam veterans groups in the Chicago
area getting involved with with
supporting them back in the early 80s my
wife's two brothers served in Vietnam
and her sister's husband also with a
combat medic in Vietnam so when I met
her in 1970 we started dating and we got
married in 81 we started dating dating
in 76 she was a part of the early
history of stéfano from the early
ensemble she introduced me to her
brothers and her sisters husband and I
asked them about Vietnam I started
talking to them I was I was 18 years old
in 1973 it was the last year of combat
operations in Vietnam the draft was over
in 1980
83 I recall registering for the
Selective Service but the draft was over
so and I remember during high school I'm
doing all those plays I'm playing my in
my rock band I'm chasing those girls
into the auditions and everything like
that and every night
I'm television during that time there
are casualty reports there are terrible
stories about Vietnam and my mom and is
watching the television like this and
I'm calling my girlfriend and figuring
out what the setlist is gonna be and I
wasn't really paying attention all that
much but when I met those family members
of my wife and they started talking to
me about what it was like for them to be
in Vietnam and then what it was like for
them to come home from Vietnam to a
nation that had turned it to back on our
on our military and had rejected the
Vietnam veteran something happened to me
I just started thinking about that a lot
and I remember taking over as artistic
director for Steppenwolf and one of the
things I wanted to do was find some
material that I could do there was pho
just on the stories of Vietnam veterans
and I read this so as an artistic
director you're always looking for plays
and you get all these publications from
different cities that have the lists of
plays that are going on in those cities
and what's going on so I I would do that
and I got one thing that was from LA
called the drama log it was kind of
what's going on in sort of live small
theaters in LA and I read this story
about a play that was written by a group
of Vietnam veterans and where they were
actually performing the play that they
that they wrote so every night these
guys would recreate their own stories of
what happened to them in Vietnam on
stage and it got very good reviews it
was a big hit it sounded very powerful I
immediately got on an airplane and flew
out to see it it's 1980 and I was just I
was just knocked out I went back the
next night and saw it again
and I went home to Chicago and I wrote
to the guys that did it and I said would
you consider letting me do this play to
tell your stories that you're telling
yourselves on stage every night would
you let me do that
that's definitely than they said no no
should only be performed by veterans we
don't want anybody to do it but veteran
eventually the play closed in Los
Angeles and I just kept asking them you
know what are you gonna do with it well
no no no and eventually we were doing a
play in Chicago the Malkovich had
directed and it was called balm in
Gilead by Lanford Wilson and it was
high-performance Street it was good took
place in a diner like a seedy diner in
New York so it's got all the night
people out there the the hookers and the
pimps and the drug addicts and the the
junkies and the you know the crazy
people running around it was like 38
people on stage all just being crazy you
know and it was very high-energy and we
put Springsteen music in it we put Tom
Waits music in and we put Ricky Lee
Jones and was just very you know a very
Steppenwolf that was kind of our thing
and
so I said I said to this guy John defuse
Co who had created this play tracers
about these Vietnam veterans I said come
see it so he flew out he saw it and he
would he loved it and then he gave me
the rights to do the play I did it
they're veterans from all over the area
came to see the play a lot of Vietnam
veterans and this isn't 1984 so this was
you know the the Vietnam veteran wall
had just opened in 1982 so this was
still a time where Vietnam veterans were
just not used to coming out of the
shadows and telling their stories but
our play became this rallying point and
veterans would come from all over and we
ended up creating a night at Steppenwolf
every week that was just simply for the
veterans and that began a series of
events and things of my that that laid
the bedrock for my veterans work going
into the 90s and then post September
11th so in just a second don't ask you
about Lieutenant Dan how was to play
that part and your work with the USO and
and generally what people don't get
about the military but first let's talk
about your impending doom life insurance
is one of these topics that everybody
knows a little bit about but do you
understand it well enough to feel
comfortable buying life insurance
whether you're an insurance expert or a
newbie policy genius created a website
that makes it easy for you to compare
quotes get advice and then get covered
policy genius is the easy way to get
life insurance in minutes you can
compare quotes from top insurers and
find the coverage you need at a price
you can afford from there you just apply
online the advisors at policy genius
will handle all the red tape for you
they will even negotiate your rate with
the insurance company no extra fees no
Commission sales agents just helpful
advice and personalized service policy
genius doesn't just make life insurance
easy whether you're shopping for
disability insurance or homeowners
insurance or auto insurance they can
help you get covered fast so no matter
how much or how little you know about
life insurance you can find the right
policy in minutes of policy genius.com
don't be buried in a pauper's grave make
sure your family has the money that they
need in case something should god forbid
happen to you and your plots go check
them out policy genius.com policy genius
is the easy way to compare and buy life
insurance already so let's talk a little
bit about Forrest Gump and Lieutenant
and how that changed your perspective on
the military so obviously you were
already
credibly pro-military you already wanted
to tell the stories of people who had
served and and done that amazing work
what changed your perspective about
playing lieutenant in I remember when I
did of mice and men and that I think got
the attention a little bit of the
producers of Forrest Gump at least it
got me an audition you know here's a guy
who directed and produced and is one of
the two two main guys in the movie that
got the attention of the producers and
the director Robert Zemeckis so I got an
audition and I read it and I was going
to audition to play a Vietnam veteran
and here I was you know I was had been
supporting Vietnam veterans for 10 12
years at that point I in various ways
very much wanted to play that part that
just you know I directed that play
tracers I had a cast of guys that were
just amazing in and all playing the
Vietnam veterans I wanted to be them I
wanted to be up there doing that myself
but I was the director and it was my
passion project
now here's an opportunity for me to play
a Vietnam veteran in a way to honor my
wife's two brothers and their sisters
husband and all the many Vietnam
veterans that I had had met it was a
great story a story of a Vietnam veteran
the nation' he ends well up until that
point you know they started making
movies about Vietnam about 1978 three
years after the fall of Saigon and there
was the deer hunter and coming home and
casualties of war and these various
movies started but you always wondered
at the end of those films if the Vietnam
veterans was going to be ok yeah at the
end of every one of those movies you're
just not sure if he's gonna be a be ok
at the end of coming home one of them
kills themselves you know and at the end
of the deer hunter you know at the end
of the deer hunter you're just you're
just like it was always tragic and and
you just didn't see any way for the
Vietnam
to be ok along comes Forrest Gump and he
goes through all that same despair and
anguish and heartbreak and you know
loneliness and anger and all these
things but what happens at the end of
that story he's successful he's wealthy
he's married he's moving on with his
life he's standing up on new legs he's
moving on and it's a happy ending for a
Vietnam veteran we haven't seen that
movie that story but yet that story was
the story of many Vietnam veterans it
just hadn't been told there were many
Vietnam veterans came back and while
there are many that struggled for many
many years there were also many that
were able to put their service years
behind them and move on in business and
and be ok and here along comes
Lieutenant Dan and that's his story so I
very much wanted to play that part I was
lucky to get it it introduced me to an
organization called the DAV disabled
american veterans which i've supported
now for 25 years because you know almost
25 years ago i'm about a month after the
movie open they invited invited me to
come to their national convention i tell
the story in the book and they gave me
an award for playing lieutenant dan
yeah and they wanted to honor me for
playing lieutenant dan in what they
thought was an honest portrayal of a
catastrophic ly injured soldier and they
just felt it was it was so many the
members of the DAV are Vietnam veterans
themselves they just wanted to recognize
that work and that began our
relationship as I said has lasted 25
years every year I go to their National
Convention I played concerts for them
I've done PSAs I've done fundraising
different things for them many friends
within the DAV we have a program at my
foundation that's in partnership with
the DAV that really started me focusing
on our wounded then along comes
September 11th and we deploy to Iraq and
Afghanistan our
I started galas you know our folks
started getting hurt
started getting killed and I was just I
just could not sit by and do nothing you
know that was such a devastating attack
on our country and now we were deploying
in reaction to that and it was also
became kind of a divisive time because
as you recall during the Iraq war after
we went into Iraq in 2003 then 2004 five
six seven things started getting getting
worse there's an insurgency there was
Abu Ghraib there was all these things
during those years you could just see it
I mean what was happening and the
coverage of it and it was very similar
to what was what had happened in the
Vietnam War things were just not going
well and you know I just pictured our
guys sitting over there watching
televisions thinking gosh things are not
going well and I'm sitting right here
saying it on the news every night and
and I didn't want our folks deploying in
reaction to that terrible event people
that were signing up because of those
airplanes going into those buildings I
didn't want them to feel that they were
being neglected or that the country
would was going to turn its back on them
or something
and it was a divided time if you recall
some people supported George Bush and
the efforts to to go into Iraq and
Afghanistan some people didn't and it
was it was being there was a very
divided time and I wanted to help you
know I wanted to help our servicemembers
get through it so and you know just
personally and I say this in the book my
heart was just broken after that
terrible day it was broken and I needed
to do something to to help heal that and
I felt having been involved with Vietnam
veterans wounded veterans through the
DAV in the 80s and 90s my role now with
would be to support the active duty
folks that were
spawning to that attack yeah I know you
tore plenty in with with members of the
military meeting members of the military
and do you have any sort of memories
that stick out of that time cuz you've
obviously done a ton of it and met an
enormous number of members of the Armed
Services yeah just just all throughout
all the travels and everything I tell
you know a number of stories in the book
about that have affected me and that
have galvanized my my passion for for
making sure that we don't forget what
our defenders do for us on a daily basis
and some of those stories are in the
book and I remember the you know I tell
a story about as a kid I remember when
my grandmother passed away and she was
in her 60s and she was a heavy smoker
and she just wasted away in the hospital
and I went to see her and I was just so
I loved my grandmother and I was just
heartbroken seeing her just laying in
the bed and it was a it was terrible and
I just ran out of the hospital and I
never wanted to go back and go back to a
hospital unless I was on a gurney you
know and when I started doing USO my
first trip was to Iraq in June of 2003
then I came back then I went and in July
three weeks later I went to Italy
visited troops there and then about a
month later I would in August I was in
Germany visiting troops there I just
want I just went boom boom boom I was
going didn't have a job at the time and
one of the things I was gonna do in
Germany was go to Landstuhl Medical
Center which is the main hospital in
Germany where people come right off the
battlefield and they go to the hospital
and they're stabilized in Germany and
then they're sent home to the States to
one of the hospitals here and I was very
apprehensive about going I didn't I you
know I was just like what's it going to
be
like you know hospitals I guy I can't
stand the thought of it and I remember
my grandmother withering away and it's
just just it was a bad and I thought and
now I'm gonna see guys who have been
blown up shot at and burned up I was
very nervous about it I remember sit I
can remember sitting on the bus as the
bus approached the hospital and we pull
in this little van and we pull up and
just as we pull up a big bus pulls up
and a whole bunch of people run out of
the hospital and they start unloading
Gurney's that have just come off the
airplane from the battlefield sent back
to the hospital wires and tubes and you
know IVs and you know everything and
they're you know there's these guys are
all stabilized but they got to get in
there because they got surgery right
away as soon as I get to the hospital
and that team ran out so professionally
getting them out of that out of those
buses quickly and I just stood there and
watched this was the first thing I saw
at the hospital like seven or eight
wounded guys being carried into the
hospital on Gurney's all with wires and
missing legs and all this I was just
like okay take a deep breath here you
know and they first took me into a room
that had about 30 guys in it and these
were all guys that were banged up cuts
bruises gunshot wounds whatever it was
but they were gonna get patched up and
sent back to the battlefield and they
were all in there and they were waiting
you know gel on their face from burns or
whatever you know they were gonna get
fixed up and sent back to the war zone I
walked in and I had a USO hat on and I'm
like this is remember this is before CSI
New York so I was lieutenant Dan but you
know I hadn't done much else so I didn't
know what to say or how to start it and
somebody looked at me and he said
Lieutenant Dan and he and he burst into
a smile and they all had these
thousand-yard stairs on
you know they were quiet in there it was
quiet nobody was saying anything and
then one guy just lit up and started
smiling calling me Lieutenant Dan then
everybody started coming around and
laughing and taking pictures and all of
a sudden the whole mood in the room just
completely changed nobody knew what my
real name was they just saw me from the
movie and they wanted to talk about the
movie and I saw gosh and then I left
that room after being in there for
ninety minutes or so shaking hands and
taking pictures signing off autographs
to go upstairs to the hospital rooms but
I knew when I left that room gosh I just
brought something into that room that
was really really positive it change it
changed the whole mood in the room just
showing up so I went upstairs and that's
when I saw a lot of really badly wounded
people some didn't even know I was there
but their family members had flown it
from the states to Germany and they were
standing over hospital beds of amputees
and waiting for them to wake up and I
changed their mood just by showing up
I'll never forget that because it
started a whole journey of trying to
support our wounded that I've been on
ever since well it's an it's an amazing
thing and it's also I would imagine
something that keeps you grounded I mean
I've lived in Hollywood my entire life
you've been out here longer than life
but the fact is that Donna remar me but
the fact is that you see so many people
who you know are very wealthy and very
famous who seem to have lost their
grounding in reality and and you have it
and do you think that your your book
you'll between your family life and your
work with the troops that that's what's
helped to keep you grounded and on solid
ground partially and partially my just
the the background from working in a
basement you know for all those years
you know with with actors you know a lot
of the actors that were with us in those
early days Joan Allen Laurie Metcalf as
I said Malkovich Jeff Perry you know a
lot of folk Gary Cole a lot of a lot of
folks are all just sort of grounded in
this Illinois thing that we had
at that time and they remember the days
where we all worked for free we didn't
get any money and everybody was just
doing it for the love of it that game
that gave us a lot of I think a good
good fundamentals you know when we moved
away from that into something that we
had all had to struggle for you know
nobody came out here you know and just
got handed stuff right away I mean
everybody kind of you know work worked
their way up
you know Malkovich was a little bit
different because we went he start we
went to New York he started doing movies
after that but you know everybody had a
pretty good grounding I think once we
once we started moving into the movie
business already and just simply because
we remember you know there wasn't always
you know glamorous and all that there
was there was a struggle for a lot of
folks to to get there and I remember
that and and certainly you know when you
go to the war zones and you see how
people are living in the war zones and
you live with them that way for a little
bit and you eat what they eat you sleep
on what they sleep on and and all of
that now and you continue to do that it
gives you a it's a reality check for
sure so I know that right now you're
spending an awful lot of time on touring
and I want to hear about what happens
after the tour is over what are your
plans for the future to have that
question answered however you need to go
over to Daley wire.com and subscribe
it's the only way you're gonna get to
hear the answer to that question and
more behind the paywall it's $9.99 a
month and we provide you all sorts of
goodies I mean it's not just the rest of
this show it's also the rest of my daily
show which means two additional hours
per day all sorts of great stuff go
check it out over at daily wire com
alright Gary's book is grateful American
a journey from self to service everybody
should go check it out and Gary thanks
so much for stopping by really
appreciate you that's my pleasure but
thank you
[Music]
eventually rose shows Sunday special is
produced by Jonathan hey executive
producer Jeremy boring associate
producer Mathis Glover edited by Donovan
Fowler audio is mixed by Dylan Kate's
hair and makeup is by Joshua alvera
title graphics by Cynthia and Guillot
the Ben Shapiro shows Sunday special is
a daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 19
[Music]